Legends of hip-hop celebrating the 50th
anniversary of the music in the same way
it started with a party in the Bronx New
York
Public Enemy a group that Rose to
prominence in the 80s with its political
messages performed with others for free
in this public park recalling the art
form's humble beginnings government and
the city left left this area for dead
and long and the people along with them
and um it started like even putting the
expressway through such you know a place
like the Bronx Harlem is right over
there and when the city left the people
for dead out of those ashes Rose hip-hop
Sparky D took part in some legendary rap
battles back in the day but says the
music at its core is about building
Community to know that we invented this
thing to know that we would jump on the
train in Brooklyn and run to the Bronx
it runs you know to Manhattan and just
to be in all kind of events with the
music in the park come on imagine
plugging them music in the lamp post but
we
we wouldn't we didn't even think that we
would be here 50 years later it was
Community it was Unity it was love and
peace and that's what hip-hop stands for
it's also graffiti art and break dancing
and after 50 years it's now a
multi-billion dollar industry
Rocky bucano executive director of the
universal hip-hop Museum says it
resonates around the world as the music
of the marginalized they use it
for social justice they use it for
political movements they use it for
profits become entrepreneurs whether
fashion designers or you know production
music producers or even
today hip-hop is in film television
advertising
[Music]
come a long way in 50 years hip-hop is
now one of the most popular music Styles
in the world
but neither it's performers nor their
fans have forgotten where it all started
Kristen salumi Al Jazeera the Bronx New
York